okay I talk to you after the november
eighth election of president elect
Donald about the failure of corporate
media to really keep us as an informed
electorate in a real and important way
and I said listen we need to support
independent media that's what it is and
I'm so flattered that the audience has
responded because we've had record
membership sign ups by the 13th of this
month we already had more new members
subscribed than we've ever had in an
entire calendar month in the history of
the show the big thing we are going to
do and conversations are moving ahead
very quickly as we are going to be
launching a fundraiser and somewhere
between 10 and 14 days and the point of
this fundraiser is going to be
specifically to make independent media
more than just people talking about
different ideas or in a different way
than corporate media we are going to be
having a progressive engagement
coordinator who is going to be
organizing and coordinating progressive
action on issues on candidates this will
be part of the David Pakman show website
but it will have its own portal for
people who want to get engaged we are
going to be very actively talking on the
show about here is a specific election
issue or activist project that we can
all work on together to actually achieve
change because just talking on non
corporate media as great as it is is
clearly not enough or at least it wasn't
in this only 16 election to prevent some
really horrible things from happening we
are going to be doing some studio
upgrades that is already something that
we are starting to plan and it is also
going to be part of this fundraiser we
are also i I'm so excited about this but
it requires a lot of work the david
pakman show is coming to amazon prime
and this is just such a major major
thing and it's basically uh youtube is
already a major part of the distribution
of the show amazon prime could be as big
or bigger over the long term it requires
a whole other infrastructure and it's a
whole other process and right now
everybody who's currently working with
us everybody's really maxed out so
that's going to be part of this new
position that we're going to be creating
and we're also going to be creating a
network of progressive non-core
shows that will together with our
progressive engagement uh coordinator be
actually mobilizing everybody's audience
to really take action so all this is
going to be happening we'll have more
news about in the next 10 to 14 days if
you want to be an early donor please get
in touch you have ideas for the
fundraiser please get in touch but know
that this is coming and in the meantime
you can use coupon code I voted 17 at
david pakman.com slash membership to get
forty percent off of your membership you
can also go to david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 to get a free 2017 david
pakman show calendar with your
membership